all right so jimmy you've been very
vocal which i appreciate um because we
have
gigantic platforms that i think we
should use um but you've been pretty
vocal about black lives matter
so what do you think personally
um that we can all do differently i
think the first step
is educating ourselves we have a lot of
time on our hands right now there is no
reason why we shouldn't be watching
these movies watching
um and absorbing all information that we
possibly can about what's going on in
the world
and then from there you know we've we've
seen it
all over the media that that being
silent
and being not racist is not enough
anymore and
that's kind of something that i posted
but posted about
um like a month ago when
the ahmad arbory stuff happened i i was
like
i felt i i saw online what had happened
and i felt this overwhelming sense of
like
frustration anger i was like crying and
i started writing in my phone um
i just got out all my emotions and i
felt guilty that i hadn't been
doing more and saying more um as an ally
but i was also afraid um
that people were going to come at me
um because they will yes because
everybody's angry right now and i just i
didn't want anyone to think that i had
the wrong intentions
or that i was uneducated you know like
um
speaking about something that i didn't
know about that it was a fear of mine
and
so i kind of when that happened i
and even before or before i found out
about george floyd i was like
no i need to do more i need to be an
ally i have not been an ally i have
like aretha franklin billy holliday
whitney houston these women of color
have like shaped my
musical journey and how am i supposed to
appreciate what they've given me and not
stand up for
their community and so i just i i
switched
my thinking and then all of this
happened and
um you know i wish i had kind of come to
that realization sooner but
i think everything happens in its own
timing um
and i've now gotten to a place where
like because i'm able to deal with my
own demons my own things i can
now kind of help um advocate for other
people
and i think maybe that's a reason why
some people aren't speaking out and
doing things as they're afraid but
they're also like not ready to help
other people
um i don't know i just wanted to be
the ally that i know i can be and
i want to be able to shift thinking as
much as possible because
my the legacy that i will leave as a
person will last so much longer than the
music that we leave behind
yeah totally your character means
everything i agree
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going